[Música]
bienvenidos a en 5 minutos con nos
acompaña el doctor carlos eduardo pérez
asesor científico de france 24 y médico
infectólogo de la universidad nacional
de colombia gracias por acompañarnos
doctor la uem se ha celebrado el regreso
de eeuu a la organización mundial de la
salud al igual que el anuncio de
incorporar al país al programa kóvacs el
de distribución de vacunas que
represente este nuevo giro político para
la lucha contra el kobe 19 a nivel
mundial
sin duda la vacuna alan es un propósito
mundial y la estrategia kóvacs una
estrategia gabi necesita es que todos
los países estén para que todos los
países para tener acceso también a la
vacuna en la forma universal los países
ricos y los países pobres pero esto se
necesita capital y se necesita que todos
estemos ahí el hecho de que estados
unidos refuerce va a decir que hay más
vacuna mayor accesibilidad mayor flujo
de dinero para que haya la discusión de
la vacuna en todo el mundo de recordemos
que una vez eres para todos y no para
solamente los que tienen acceso con o
hablemos ahora de europa doctor reino
unido registró este miércoles la cifra
más alta de fallecidos por kobe 19 mil
ochocientos veinte personas en 24 horas
está fallando algo en el proceso de
vacunación con países
no los procesos de vacunación en este
momento son lentos por la exposición del
biológico y se está priorizando
solamente a la población de salud y que
tenga una edad mayor de 80 años pero
esto es incipiente solamente se ha
vacunado el 12 por ciento de las
poblaciones es todavía insuficiente para
poder medir el impacto lo hace lo que
vemos ahora es la dispersión de los
linajes lo que pasó en diciembre la
situación de invierno que hace que en
los hogares estén más personas y haya
mayor probable de contagios y
definitivamente que los los servicios de
salud tampoco han tenido la respuesta
grande y están colapsando en todo el
mundo entonces este es un llamado a que
de nuestra región anticipemos a estas
situaciones que estamos viendo en duro
y cómo han sido las mutaciones
emergentes del virus doctor combatirán
las vacunas efectivamente estas nuevas
variantes
recuerden que las variantes siempre
suceden entre mayor tasa de contagio
porque la mayor en la mayoría de
personas infectadas hay mayor pérdida el
virus camps aquí en estos linajes van a
aparecer en américa latina sin ninguna
duda
si nosotros disminuimos la aceleración
de contagio probablemente tenga menos
podría de aparecer los linajes hoy no
vacuna de facer y en estudios que
muestran que para el linaje el reino
unido es efectiva pero no sabemos para
unas futuras por eso tiene que haber
vacunación con desaceleración de los
casos si hay preocupación en reino unido
y en europa donde la propagación del
virus no mengua en su tercera ola y
donde van más adelantados en sus planes
de vacunación y de protección que le
espera entonces a nuestra región a
américa latina
nosotros como américa latina' siempre
hemos tenido la oportunidad de ver el
futuro lo que pasa en europa dos o tres
meses después y nosotros debemos
aprender de eso si nosotros todos
hubiéramos hecho estrategias diferentes
en diciembre probablemente no tuviéramos
el impacto de esta segunda ola no quiere
decir que no lo hubiéramos tenido pero
no con este impacto nosotros necesitamos
vacunar pronto masivamente y ofrecer la
vacuna a la mayor parte de población
nuestro enfoque crítica es vacunar para
poder disminuir la probabilidad de la
aceleración de los casos como están
sucediendo en europa y en el reino unido
pero eso va a depender de variables
políticas sociales logísticas y
económica américa latina tiene la mitad
de los contagios en el mundo en este
momento y algunos hospitales ya están
colapsados y otros trabajan al límite de
su capacidad
cuál es el panorama en el corto plazo si
se sigue con este aumento de casos
si nosotros estamos atendiendo a que
tenemos un sistema de salud en la
mayoría de estos países frágil
estos 10 meses sirvió para prepararnos
un poco mejor pero no es suficiente
definitivamente el sistema de salud de
nuestros países y se ha comprobado es
reactivo nosotros pensamos que el gran
triunfo es tener cama de tu antes sido
lo que necesitamos que las partes no
lleguen al claro entendido que no
requieran un ventilador
hoy tenemos que hacer todo lo posible
para optimizar nuestros recursos
priorizar la vacunación y
definitivamente mantener las medidas de
restricción para esa cerveza desacelerar
el número de casos y empezar la
estrategia vacunación como se está
haciendo en algunos países de américa
latina' pronto si vacunamos desacelera
mos confinamos y mantenemos el servicio
de salud optimizado vamos a poder lograr
en este par de meses sortear esta
situación tan compleja pues muchas
gracias doctor carlos eduardo pérez
asesor científico de france24 médico
infectólogo gracias a ustedes siga con
nosotros aquí en france 24
[Música]